the fbi worries about the possibility of
new riots and attacks from fringe trump
supporters
democrats push toward a second
impeachment and democrats say they're
all for unity but there are a few
conditions
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
[Music]
show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
your online activity should not be
public protect yourself at
expressvpn.com
we'll get to all the news in just one
moment first a quick reminder
things are really bad and you know what
in the future they're probably not going
to be a whole lot better
at least where your finances are
concerned unless you are diversified
because the reality is that we are about
to enter an era of one party control
we have seen the tsunami of cultural
warfare against people
on the right and that's going to have
some financial implications okay
fiscally you can expect compounded
growth of the national debt
you can expect the devaluation of the us
dollar so what are you going to do right
now to protect your savings and your
retirement well your answer is you're
going to diversify into precious metals
with my friends
over at birch gold group birch gold
group will help you diversify a portion
of your savings in ira or eligible 401k
into an ira backed by gold and silver
they're the premier precious metals ira
company in america they've got an a plus
better business bureau rating countless
five-star reviews thousands of satisfied
customers there's a title wave of
inflation coming and gold
would be your hedge text ben to 47 47 47
for your free information kit on
precious metals ira or to speak with a
birch gold representative today there's
a reason that china is looking very
optimistically
at their future economy versus the
united states you should diversify just
to protect your assets
time is running out you can protect your
savings right now by texting ben to 47
47 47
asking all your questions and my friends
at birch gold group and then getting
started
in your diversification mission text ben
47-47 to get in touch with my friends
over at birch gold group okay so we
begin
with the big news of the day which is
that the fbi is saying that
this very well might not be over all of
the chaos that we saw
last week that attempted insurrection
inside the capitol building which was an
attempt to overthrow the results
of the election by a fringe group of
nut cases and and badly motivated people
who decided they were going to invade
the capitol building
some of whom were carrying zip ties it
turns out that we found out that that
there were people
outside with vans full of explosive
materials multi-cocktail materials
we know that there was a pipe bomb that
was left over at the rnc and this could
have been really really really a lot
worse
i mean seriously that's i think the big
takeaway from
all the information that we are now
receiving in the aftermath of the attack
last week is that this thing could have
been a whole hell of a lot worse
for example i mean it was bad as it was
there's all this new footage that has
emerged
since last week so if all you saw was
sort of the images from outside the
building
and and those images were mainly just
people cheering on the ramparts sort of
uh that was not the uh that was not the
extent of it cops were literally getting
pulled into crowds of people who were
beating them with american flags it was
disgusting
it's disgusting anybody who did this
should go to jail and they should throw
away the key here's a little bit of that
footage from last week
you can see in the middle of the footage
people
attempting to to literally just wail on
uh on police officers there's somebody
attempting to beat a police officer with
an american flag which of course is uh
one of the uh worst symbolic sites that
i've seen in recent memory
somebody attempting to hit a police
officer with the trump flag
really really ugly stuff police officers
seriously injured they can see them down
there
on the ground there's also footage that
was uh that came out
last week of a police officer being
crushed
as people attempted to force their way
into the capitol building
super disturbing images here as police
officers attempt to keep people from
invading
the seat of democracy
[Music]
and a police officer being crushed in
the middle of this melee
i mean this is scary stuff and again
anybody who's identi uh there's a police
officer
okay any uh any piece of crap who
participated in this again
should go to jail and they should throw
away the key we now have
news that um a a bunch of folks have
been arrested because they were
identified there are a lot of questions
about why weren't more people arrested
the answer is
you don't arrest all that many people at
the riot when you're short staffed the
big problem here
is that the police didn't have enough
people when you arrest somebody you then
have to delegate somebody to actually
maintain the arrest right or the person
gets up and they run away
you have to make sure that you are you
have enough people on the front lines to
prevent
more of this and to clear the building
well now it turns out that a lot of the
people who have been identified have
been arrested in other areas of the
country
according to fox 13 at memphis a man in
nashville was charged in connection with
the riots of the us capital on wednesday
eric munchel is accused of being one of
two men who stormed the us capital with
zip ties which is scary scary stuff
obviously
the zip ties when you see those you have
to imagine what he meant to do
was actually take hostages zip tie
members of congress or the vice
presidents of the united states
he's charged with knowingly entering or
remaining in any restricted building or
grounds without lawful authority and
violent entry and disorderly conduct on
capitol grounds
larry brock of texas was also arrested
for entering the capital during the riot
with zip ties
he faces similar charges it is alleged
that both of these
not good people uh were uh were
invading the capitol building in order
to restrain or detain subjects and the
cases are going to be prosecuted by the
federal government
uh we also have many more people
arrested including a man with 11 molotov
cocktails
this again according to
nbcwashington.com authorities say
they've charged several riders
who were allegedly captured in photos
and videos that went viral in the
aftermath including an arizona man seen
in a horned hat and carrying a spear
and a florida man accused of carrying
through the capitol a lectern that
reportedly is used
by house speaker nancy pelosi some of
these arrests have resulted in some
rather grim humor
some of that humor came a courtesy of
the lawyer for
adam johnson who is the guy who stole
the podium who
had to admit to the reporters yeah you
know i'm a lawyer i'm not a miracle
worker there is tape of the man walking
through the capitol building carrying a
podium so i'm not sure what you want
from
here part of what you have to you know
factor into is again you just have to
drill down on what actually happened you
have a photograph of our client
you know in a building um you know
unauthorized to be there with
uh you know what appears to be a podium
or a lecture not exactly sure which one
it's called
but that's what we have obviously that
presents problems for you as a defense
attorney in that you have your client
in the building at the time of the uh
break-in
yeah yeah i don't know the you know how
to explain that but yeah that's that's
that would be a problem i'm not a
magician and neither is mr big knee so
yeah we've got a photograph of our
client
who appears to be inside the federal
building or inside the capital with the
government property
well um yeah i mean sometimes lawyers
don't have
the greatest jobs uh in a piece of uh
another piece
of grimly ironic but somewhat humorous
news to come out of this uh that that
stupid idiot
who was um in dangerous idiot who
invaded the capitol building dressed
like a barbarian
his name is jacob chansley 33 one of the
maga rioters who turned himself into the
fbi for his part in storming the capitol
building
late on wednesday uh apparently he has
been living with his mother since
january 2019.
he's a real man's man over here his mom
revealed her son has not eaten since his
arrest on saturday because the jail
where he is being held does not offer
organic food does not offer organic food
so um yeah yeah
all i can say is uh don't eat your
heart's content dude
fast your heart's content doesn't offer
organic food
ah and these people thought that they
were saving the republic as opposed to
destroying the republic
well done everybody well done everybody
okay well all of this
is all predicate to the fbi suggesting
that they have received information
indicating armed protests are being
planned
at all 50 state capitals and the u.s
capital in washington d.c in the days
leading up to president
elect biden's inauguration on january
20th according to an internal bulletin
obtained by cnn
the news comes as security measures are
being stepped up ahead of inauguration
day with federal state and local law
enforcement agencies preparing for the
possibility
of more violence after riders stormed
the us capital last week leaving five
people dead including a capital police
officer
even as federal investigators continue
to track down suspects from last week's
attack the bulletin highlights concerns
the capital siege was perhaps just the
beginning of potentially violent
actions from trump supporters who
believe that the
election was stolen and that they have
the authority power
and incentive to uh to overturn the
democratic election
process according to the fbi bulletin
armed protests are being planned at all
50 state capitals from january 16th or
at least january 20th
at the u.s capitol from 17 january
through 20th of january it suggests
there are threats of an uprising if
trump is removed via the 25th amendment
before inauguration day uh according to
the bulletin
on january 8 the fbi received
information on an identified group
calling for others to join them in
storming
state local and federal government
courthouses and administrative buildings
in the event
the president is removed as president
prior to inauguration day the identified
group is also planning to storm
government offices including dc and in
every state regardless
of whether the state's certified
electoral votes were biden or trump
on january 20th the fbi is in fact
tracking
all of this meanwhile the government
held continuity of government operations
a standard practice
in the event that someone tries to
disrupt the transition that took on a
new urgency
in light of uh everything that has been
happening obviously
meanwhile security preparations were
complicated when the acting
director of homeland security uh
resigned wolf
this would be this would be um chad
wolfe the acting secretary of homeland
security
uh he had instructed the us secret
service to begin
the national special security event
operations for the inauguration
on wednesday instead of january 19th the
day before biden was set to be
inaugurated
but he says that he is done in light of
events of the past weekend the evolving
security landscape leading up to the
inauguration at the recommendation of
the secret service director james murray
have instructed the us secret service to
begin
the national special security event
operations for the 2021 inauguration
effective on wednesday january 13th
instead
of on january 19th wolff said
meanwhile many many officers are being
sent to
central areas with regard to government
the national guard is now planning to
have 15
000 national guard troops to meet the
current and future request for the
inauguration
remember that time when it was really
really bad that tom cotton suggested in
the pages of the new york times
that the national guard ought to be
called into quell riots and the entire
democratic party went nuts and in fact
the editorial staff
at the new york times suggested that
this is a threat of violence against
them
remember that and then the op-ed editor
at the new york times
lost his job for even running that op-ed
well democrats are all tom cotton now so
congratulations for coming around to
reality where it turns out that riots
should be handled by the national guard
if that is what it requires
in order to stop rioting and mass
violence
the nypd is going to be sending 200
officers to washington to assist
in the inauguration also law enforcement
agencies in virginia maryland and jersey
are going to send officers to dc for the
inauguration
as well so that is where things stand
right now now would be an excellent time
by the way to suggest that you also head
over to gofundme
and donate some money for the family of
brian siknik he's the officer
who was who was killed uh in the middle
of this
awful riot and um and pathetic
insurrection
attempt this is a it is a verified
gofundme
um lindsay taylor is the is the leader
of the fundraiser
they've raised about six hundred
thousand dollars at this point brian was
a was a veteran a new jersey native who
served in the new jersey air national
guard
uh he served his country stateside and
in operations overseas
as well he joined the u.s capitol police
in july 2008.
uh the gofundme page was created on
behalf of brian's family with their
permission it was being managed by a
u.s capitol police officer who served
with officer siknik so
if you have a little bit of extra money
lying around head on over to gofundme
and donate it to the brian
siknik memorial fund okay now
with all of this said with all this
happening one of the things that is also
happening that
perhaps the the thing with longer term
ramifications here
is the is the attempt to lump in
every single person who disagrees with
the democratic agenda of course of
course of course he knew this was going
to happen
with the with the rioters and the
insurrectionists and the criminals who
invaded the capital
last week right this has been i've been
saying this for a week since this
happened that it was fairly obvious
where the left where the media were
going to go with us
and they are indeed going there it is it
is going to make the country more
polarized and worse
it's going to be a very very very bad
moment for the country
and i think that it is going to have
some really long-term ramifications
we'll get to that in just one second
first
let's talk about something brighter
let's talk about you saving money so the
reality is you're spending too much
money on your cell phone bill
you're spending way too much money on
your cell phone bill maybe like twice as
much money as you need to be spending
on your cell phone bill well many
americans say their top new year's
resolution is to save money
in the next year let's check that box
right now when your family switches to
pure talk from a t verizon or t-mobile
you could save over 800 bucks a year
that's real money every single month
right back in your pocket you're not
gonna have to sacrifice coverage
puretalk is on the same network as one
of the big carriers but they charge you
half
that's right no gimmicks no fluff added
to your bills which is why pure talk is
the top rated wireless company by
consumer affairs how about this offer
right now
get unlimited talk text and six gigs of
data for just 30 bucks a month
if you go over on data usage they're not
going to charge you for it so grab your
mobile phone dial pound 250
say ben shapiro when you do you'll save
50 off your first month dial pounds 250
say keyword ben shapiro pure talk usa is
simply smarter wireless again
grab that mobile phone dial pound 250
say ben shapiro and you'll say 50
off your first month plus a lot of money
overall because you're switching to pure
talk from one of the more expensive
wireless carriers go check them out
right now pure talk usa now pal250
say keyword ben shapiro to get started
okay so the the push now is of course to
lump
every single person on the right in with
the pathetic
disgusting people who decided to invade
the capitol building and threaten
american lawmakers in the middle of an
attempt to certify a duly held and
certified election
right that's the attempt to the left and
that's the attempt of the media because
never let a good crisis go to waste we
have seen it in social media with the
tech bros
shutting down parlor we have seen it in
the media itself
with calls from members of the media to
literally oust
anybody who voted for president trump
suggesting that they were part of the
conspiracy or at least they went and
nodded at all of this or they knew it
was going to happen
that it was entirely foreseeable in
every possible way
and here it is not what about ism to
point out
that the that the left has completely
looked the other way on black lives
matter
riot and so they don't actually get to
hold the standard that
if you use inflammatory rhetoric and
then some people
misuse the rhetoric to go out and do act
of violence then you are responsible for
that because they
that literally is not their standard
right that literally is not their
standard
and that is especially it's especially
not the standard for broad-scale
republicans many of whom
have not been suggesting that the
election was stolen
and yesterday the washington post
printed a piece in which they openly
suggested that i had said the election
was stolen
that's it that's absurd you know how
much flack i've received from people for
saying that the election was not stolen
from like the very first night of the
election
when i literally said on election night
as trump came out and declared victory
that he did not
have evidence to support the idea that
he had won the election
the washington post had to retract that
but of course journalism
is uh is always done retrospectively at
a lot of these places
but don't worry they are the mainstream
establishment media who ought to be
privileged on social
networking sites like facebook and on
twitter right we at the daily wire who
have been pretty circumspect in our
coverage right pretty careful
in our coverage of all of this stuff now
we're the untrustworthy source but the
washington post that openly gets it
wrong suggesting that number one i'm an
employee of a company i'm not an
employee
of and then two suggesting that i
received a letter i didn't receive and
then three
suggesting that i had been pushing the
stolen election line
well done excellent journalism all
around but again this is about part and
parcel
of the broader idea which is that if
you're on the right you're okay with all
of this
right not only were you okay with all
this you've bought major swathes of the
republican party
have bought into all of this so for
example michael sharer
has a piece in the politics section of
the washington post
this of course is not an op-ed piece
okay
this piece by sharer is uh is also
contributed by scott clement is in the
reporting section of the washington post
excellent journalism here
and the question is whether the entire
party is q anon whether the entire
republican party is q anon
i'm not kidding the title the article is
titled war for the soul
capital riot elevates a gop power
struggle between pro-trump conspiracy
theorists and party establishment
okay so just going to point out if you
ask
the vast majority of republicans what q
anon is they have
no idea they have no idea if you ask me
for the details on what q1 is and i
follow this stuff pretty damned closely
i have no idea other than it's a wild
conspiracy theory about trump saving the
republic from child molesters or some
such nonsense
and cannibalism and weird occult rituals
it's all bizarre
it's so crazy that alex jones was on the
was on air over the past week yelling at
the q anon people
alex jones and yet the idea here is that
the entire republican party has bought
into this nonsense
so michael scherer writes this the essay
reads like the manifesto of a delusional
conspiracy theorist
claiming that president trump would
remain in office on january 20th after
purging his cabinet and replacing vice
president pence
it predicted a 12-day period of national
crisis that would likely involve an
internet blackout the use of the federal
communication commission's emergency
broadcast system and high profile
arrests
it's 1776 all over again the tract
declared
but says the washington post these were
not the ramblings of an anonymous
internet troll or some
random troublemaker this was an official
letter from the chairman of the nye
county republican party in nevada posted
friday on the organization's official
website
well i mean if some nut from the nye
county republican party in nevada
posted on their little visited website a
crazy letter clearly this implicates the
entire republican base
i'll be honest with you i've never heard
of nye county until i just said the
words nye county right now
but apparently this is representative of
like the entirety that
the the nut-picking that goes on with
regards to the media and the right is it
it's wild it's wild
okay the entire democratic party has
embraced black lives matter like fully
embraced it and downplayed riots
for months on end it's not nut-picking
to point that out
it is certainly nut-picking when you go
out and you find a letter posted
by the republican party leader in nye
county and then you're like this is
probably the entire republican party
especially because the jeremiah drew a
rebuke from michael arons the
communications director for the rnc who
called it deranged and wildly
irresponsible according to the post
but as of monday morning the post
remained with an update from party
chairman chris zimmerman
noting that a message intended for his
local community had sparked widespread
attention online
nothing in this letter was original to
me he wrote the missive by zimmerman who
did not respond to a request for comment
reflects the extent to which the
trump-inspired mob violence at the u.s
capitol last week
has elevated a long festering struggle
within the republican party over
conspiracy theories
purity tests and fealty to the rules to
the rule of law
oh really that that's the highlight for
you this is like this is the touch point
is some dumbass in ny county posted a
ridiculous piece
on their website this this obviously
implicates the entire republican party
you can see the pathetic attempt here
the pathetic attempt here
is that all republicans are the same
they've been doing this since i was a
child
every time a republican says something
bizarre every single elected and
unelected republican has asked what do
you feel about this bizarre thing that
this republican said
when todd aiken said a weird thing about
rape and abortion
the entire republican party was held to
account for his bizarre statement
right when when christine o'donnell ran
for senate
years ago and i believe it's delaware
and
there's some weird stuff about about
witchcraft or something
this was this was determined to be an
issue of chief importance for every
republican to answer to
but when it when a democrat does
something bad of course or when the
entire democratic party does something
bad and green lights it
then of course it does not implicate the
entire democratic party when illidan
omar says openly anti-semitic stuff and
the democratic congress refuses to
censor her censure her right when that
happens it doesn't
implicate anything they're still the
very tolerant wonderful and not
anti-semitic part
like the the double standard here is
insane it's insane
but of course it is part of a broader
agenda and the broader agenda is to
discredit anybody who happens to be of
conservative orientation on the back
of ideas they do not share and do not
believe in on the back of actions that
we all find abhorrent
get to more of this in a second because
it has real world ramifications first
let's talk about something amazing okay
so let me tell you
about the presto dorothy rapid cold brew
maker so i've been guzzling coffee like
nobody's business
but there's one problem i don't want hot
coffee all day sometimes i want a cold
brew
but you know if you don't have the
dorothy then you're missing out because
this machine is so cool it is awesome
okay it makes
amazing cold brew coffee so the the
presto dorothy uses a tornado to spin
coffee grounds through water to make
cold brew fast the root is smooth
it is flavorful because the grounds are
never exposed to the high temperatures
that extract
acids it's the acids that make
traditional brewed coffee bitter and
sometimes irritate your stomach the
dorothy is super easy to use so here's
what you do you insert the stirring cup
into the craft
you place the craft on the power base
you add water to the line you turn the
knob halfway
and then you will see a tornado form in
the middle you pour in two thirds of a
cup of medium ground coffee
you let the coffee swirl to the desired
strength 10 minutes for
like a lighter brew and 20 minutes for
full strength or 30 minutes for ultra
strong and then you turn it off you let
the coffee rest for five minutes
you attach the plunger with the filter
you press down slowly and evenly it
filters the coffee
and then you're good to go you pour it
over ice you add milk or cream you
sweeten the taste
and you enjoy that over the rainbow
moment because it's called the dorothy
because of the tornado it's so good it's
so good i've used this repeatedly over
the past
couple of weeks in fact i can't stop
using the product it's awesome if you
love coffee
this is a fantastic way to enjoy cold
brew head on over to
getdorothy.com that's g-e-t dorothy.com
click buy now add to cart enter promo
code ben at checkout to get 10
off and free shipping that's
getdorothy.com promo code ben at
checkout amazing amazing machine
go check them out right now by the way i
love all of presto's products right they
make the stuffer that stuffed waffle
maker this is great so you can make your
coffee and you can have your waffle all
in the morning together go check them
out right now getdorothy.com promo code
ben
at checkout okay so again the the idea
here
is that all republicans are tied into
this entire thing
as the washington post reports the
central question now hovering over
america's political landscape
is whether one of its two major parties
will allow itself to function as an
extension of q and on
and other online conspiracy theory
movements that have taken hold with a
vocal segment of the gop
or if it can emerge from the trump era
as a potential governing coalition built
around ideas
and some shared agreements on facts oh
that's the question is it yes because
there's a great threat the entire
republican party is going to be taken
over by q anon
sure i also find it amazing amazing
that the washington post says that the
central question is whether one of the
two major parties is going to be taken
over by conspiracy theories
the entire democratic party is
enthralled to a conspiracy theory about
the systemic nature of
of american evil about how america
systemically discriminates
against people of color against
minorities about how america is not a
land of freedom
it is a land of oppression and
repression that is a conspiracy theory
the idea that cops all around the nation
are discriminating against black
americans that is a conspiracy theory
unsupported by the available evidence
and the entire democratic party pushes
that but only one party is enthralled to
a conspiracy theory and it's conspiracy
theory you can't
show that republicans even believe this
q anon crap
but this is the idea one political party
is super bad and one political party is
super good
why it's almost as though that was a
pre-existing narrative that the media
had been pushing for a while
and now they have the perfect moment in
order to unleash that narrative
at full strength and there are
consequences
there are consequences right i love this
the tensions carry echoes of the tea
party uprising the power of the
republican takeover of congress
a decade ago when grassroots activists
clashed with establishment leadership
and pushed the party to the right but
the movement exposed by the capital riot
and its aftermath has taken a far darker
and anti-democratic turn a significant
minority of the republican base
supports the deadly siege of the capital
polls show while many gop officials
continue to advance trump's false claims
about the election and parrot debunked
internet theories associated with the q
anon conspiracy theory that have been
spread by the president
and his allies hey listen should
republicans disassociate from the the
election is stolen nonsense yes should
they have disassociated from that
like as soon as it became evident that
the the
evidence was not there for that
narrative of course
is that representative of the
broad-based republican party
no no it's not but you will see again
this is just the predicate
for the action right the basis is
republicans are all queuing on and
they're all
supporters of the insurrection and
there's big battle going on
but virtually everybody is on one side
there is no such right mitch mcconnell
is on the side of the riders doesn't
matter there was mitch mcconnell
standing up to the writers
kevin mccarthy is on the side of the
rioters even though kevin mccarthy is
now called for censure of the president
of the united states right they're all
on the side of the rioters they're all
on the side of conspiracy theories
the goal here is to excise from the
public debate anybody who disagrees with
the broader democratic agenda because
the democrats don't want unity over this
stuff
what they want is unity with some
strings attached and those strings
attached will be
all of their policy preferences we'll
get to this in just one second okay so
ted liu this is the perfect example so
ted lou
of california who spent years promoting
the active conspiracy theory that donald
trump was a russian plant
right he was pushing the steel dossier
stuff i mean he was on tv every night
suggesting
that the the russian conspiracy stuff
was real
so ted liu was on cnn yesterday and he
suggested
that gop members should be investigated
for inciting insurrection
here he was uh so again i think there
should be an investigation of
what some members of congress did
and depending on what they did i believe
if they incited an insurrection they
should be prosecuted
my general view is that look if i'm
working let's say
on an infrastructure bill um
i welcome anyone who wants to support
the infrastructure bill so i'm not going
to
prevent members regardless of what party
they're in from supporting or
co-sponsoring good bills
okay so if they work with me they're
good if they did something i don't like
then maybe we shouldn't
investigate them for inciting
insurrection so there's now conflation
going on between republicans doing a bad
thing and republicans doing an inciting
insurrection thing so there are about
140 republicans in the house
who voted to challenge electoral results
in places like arizona
i think that's bad i think it is based
on non-evidence i think that it was a
sign of loyalty to trump
and political convenience more than it
was in act of truth
i think all of those things i also don't
think that that counts as inciting an
insurrection considering that's an
active part of the process they may be
misusing the process
i don't think the crews and holly are
responsible for inciting an insurrection
even though they were doing a thing that
i thought was bad
and negative and raised tensions and and
promoted myth-making to the american
public i don't know that
i don't believe that that counts as
inciting insurrection but the idea of
course is that if you incited an
insurrection you can be booted from
congress
it's a very convenient way of getting
rid of your political opponents
meanwhile chris cuomo legal
was on tv suggesting that um that if you
shout fire in a crowded theater this is
all just like shouting fire in a crowded
theater
so there's chris cuomo on cnn pushing a
discredited standard of law that hasn't
been true for
at least half a century here's chris
cuomo suggesting that if you disagree
with him you're shouting fire in a
crowded theater
the first amendment is not designed to
allow you to scream fire in a crowded
theater yeah
and that's what this is well that's well
i don't know if it's equivalent to that
and i hope
telling them to come down you can
actually go after them don't let them
certify
you know that you can actually scream
crowd fire in a crowded theater that's a
misnomer but we don't want to get into
that if you do
and then people get hurt you're going to
jail meanwhile the house homeland
security chair
now is suggesting that ted cruz and josh
halley should be put on the no-fly list
the no-fly list benny thompson democrat
of mississippi
raised the issue during a monday morning
appearance on sirius xm's the joe
madison show he said there's no question
about it he said first of all these
folks in my opinion can be classified as
domestic terrorists he's talking about
the rioters
he says under normal circumstances
international terrorists are on the no
flyless these are domestic terrorists
same thing a terrorist is a terrorist no
matter who you are and then
he suggested that perhaps perhaps the
the people like haley and cruz should be
on the no-fly list
he says even a member of congress that
commits a crime you know they expel from
the body
there are ethics charges that can be
brought against those individuals and
people are looking at all this
what howli did what cruz did was
horrible what the new member from
colorado who basically tweeted
directions and everything that was going
on that's not something you do
somebody said well she's new well the
point of ignorance in law is no excuse
if you don't know
you've done something wrong okay
excellent job so law and crime reporting
that um ted cruz and josh halley should
be on the no fly list yes
that makes perfect sense we're gonna put
sitting at united states senators on the
no fly list because they did a thing
that i don't like and that i think is a
perversion of the law but is not
inciting insurrection and is not a crime
okay that's not how any of this works
but the ramifications are going to be
far more dire
in the private sphere before it gets to
the public sphere and the private sphere
there's a lot of wiggle room
there's a lot of there's a lot of
ability to create a culture of
of intolerance and a culture of
shutdowns and a culture of cancellation
there's extraordinary ability to do that
in in a free country
and that's good generally there's
extraordinary ability to do that
the big problem is that right now what
we are watching is
a one-sided takeover of virtually all
institutional power in the united states
inside and outside of government we're
going to get to that
in just one second first let's talk
about something wonderful that you can
do for your family
you want to give a great meaningful gift
to a family member to a friend to a
parent to yourself
you should head on over to
paintyourlife.com painterlife.com allows
you to get a professional hand-painted
portrait created from any photo at a
truly affordable price
you can choose from a team of
world-class artists and work with them
until every detail is perfect
their user-friendly platform lets you
order a custom-made hand-painted
portrait in less than five minutes
it's a quick and easy process you get a
hand-painted portrait in about three
weeks we got a giant portrait
of me and my wife and two of our three
children over our couch at home
and i'm very much looking forward to
adding another portrait that has all
three of our children in the very near
future because i have a cute little baby
and she's really adorable and she
deserves to be in a portrait because
she's the best
it makes an amazing birthday anniversary
wedding gift meaningful person can be
cherished forever
at painterlife.com there's no risk by
the way if you don't love the final
painting your money is refunded
guaranteed
right now as a limited time offer get 20
off your painting that is correct
20 off and free shipping to get the
special offer text the word ben
to sixty four thousand that is ben to
sixty four thousand text
my name ben and two sixty four thousand
get started at paint your life dot com
paint your life celebrate the moments
that matter most terms apply available
at paint your life dot com slash terms
again
text ben to 64 000 for an amazing
amazing
gift okay so the the ramifications of
this narrative
which is that anybody remotely
associated with trump at any point in
the past
must be disassociated from what we are
creating is a climate in which half of
americans are basically banned from the
auspices of private business
that is the direction in which we are
moving extraordinarily fast
so to take an example according to the
associated press
today corporate america is quickly
distancing itself from president trump
and his republican allies with many of
the biggest names in business goldman
sachs coca-cola ford and comcast
suspending political donations after a
trump-inspired mob ransacked the us
capital and it's deadly and violent
spree
last wednesday for now the move is about
affirming the rule of law and the clear
results of an election that will elevate
joe biden to the presidency but it also
signals that companies are growing
skittish
about lawmakers who back to trump's
false claims of election fraud possibly
depriving republicans of public backing
from business groups who until recently
were at the heart of the gop's political
brand
this is spreading like wildfire said
jeffrey sonnenfeld a professor at yale
university's management school who
consults with ceos
the us business community has interest
fully in alignment with the american
public
and not with trump's autocratic bigoted
wing of the gop
sounds like jeffrey sondenfeld is um is
definitely an objective source here
the pausing of donations announced by
many companies including marriott
american express at t jp morgan chase
dell american airlines and others was
unlikely to deliver a serious blow to
republicans in congress who voted to
overturn
biden's win sheila krumholz the
executive director of the center for
responsive politics says
these are symbolic pledges but here's
the thing
the symbolism means something because
what it means is it is saying to its own
employees
endorse any republican at your own risk
okay now
all of these corporations have the
ability to give or not give they see fit
it is indeed a free country
again i'm just going to point out that
if your standard is that you do not give
to politicians
who are involved in raising rhetorical
temperature to the point of violence
then
i don't know how you give to anybody in
the democratic party either
i really don't we saw mass violence all
throughout this year
and we have seen threats of violence
carried out against
trump supporters for years on end we
have seen this on nearly every side
so if the idea here is that you are not
as a corporation going to subsidize
anybody from a party
that has made excuses for or justified
violence
then it wouldn't only be to one side but
these same corporations
in the middle of rioting that overtook
hundreds of cities
in the middle in the middle of the year
did these corporations pull their
donations from the democratic party
as many as many members of the
democratic party continued to remain
silent about rioting that was burning
down local businesses
and shutting down cities and resulting
in people being kept inside their homes
for uh in la a week right well did any
of these businesses associate for many
of that no
many of them gave open donations to the
black lives matter group
which is a marxist group many of these
donations
encourage their employees to post black
squares in solidarity
with all of these causes many of these
same corporations decided that they were
going to cater to the woke
it it happened in every element of
american life if you turned on your tv
and you wanted to watch something in the
middle of the black lives matter riots
i just want to watch something on
entertainment you turn on amazon prime
and amazon prime was recommending to you
a bunch of of movies that were centered
on racial issues if you turn on netflix
you'd get some messaging about the
systemic nature of american barbaric
racism
right there is no way to escape it so
corporations are perfectly willing to
mirror the conspiracy theories and
violence
of the left they're just not willing to
uh to cater to it on the right now
that's fine with me they don't cater to
it on the right they shouldn't cater to
it on the right but here's the thing
they're gonna broaden it out
because they know what the blowback is
going to be do you think any of these
corporations are going to give to chip
roy
so chip roy from texas who's been a
frequent guest on the program chip roy
in the middle of this
he suggested not only was the election
not stolen he asked fellow republicans
to kind of prove the point to
disassociate from their own elections if
they thought the election was stolen
because the same people who voted on the
ballots for them
did not vote for trump right you think
any of these corporations are going to
be donating to chip roy in the near
future
who thinks they will who thinks that
corporate america is now
going to really discern on the basis of
which republicans thought what how they
give their donations or
are they going to move with the general
standard pushed by the left that only
the democratic party
can be given to with a sense of of
decency
and that any corporation that associates
in any remote way
with the right must be held to account
because after all
the right is all about incitement and
the right is all about violence this is
nothing new
and we've been dealing with this on the
right for a very long time it's now just
escalated to
to insane insane levels
we've been dealing with this on the
right with regard to folks on the left
pushing for advertisers to not work with
our show
right this has happened to nearly
everybody on the right now
we here on the on the bench bureau show
we've never asked for a boycott
from people at pod dave america if they
say anything we don't like
we don't have somebody who's dedicated
full-time to listening to left-wing
shows and then pushing
companies to boycott those shows based
on their support for
various causes that we find to be bad
for the country the left has been doing
this for years with regard to the right
well now they've escalated it and they
feel like this is the opportunity to do
it
and big tech is not only not the
exception big tech is leading the way
in all this which provides some pretty
serious ramifications for the actual
practice of free speech see there's the
legal principle of free speech which is
that you have the ability to speak
freely and then there's the actual
practice of free speech
which is that if you want to speak
freely in the public square
there are really only about three or
four ways to do it realistically
speaking
there's facebook and there's twitter and
there's youtube
and that's kind of it there are not tons
of other ways for you to speak freely
right you're still at the mercy of the
big corporations you can put a podcast
up on apple podcast for as long as apple
will allow you to
you can have your website hosted but
only as long as
amazon web services allows you to so
there are only
three or four people in key
decision-making positions to decide
whether
a culture of free speech should be
allowed to
be promulgated in the united states and
a culture of free speech
really really is more important than the
law regarding free speech
if you've got a culture that says well
sure you can say what you want but it
has to be mainly in the privacy of your
own home if you ever do it in public
we're going to shut you down we're going
to remove from you the ability
to push your views in public what you're
going to end up with
is an attack on general politics sort of
like the attack that you've seen on
public expression of religion
and how many companies have been held
enthrall to
a corporate american view of religion
that has basically pushed religion into
the private domain you're gonna see the
same thing happen with generalized
political viewpoint as well
things are gonna get a lot uglier here
you know who's even warning about this
stuff
honestly you know things have gotten bad
when we're now being warned
about a crackdown on free speech by the
germans
i'm not kidding angela merkel is now
sounding off on twitter's ban
against trump she's she is not a trump
fan
obviously but she blasted twitter she
said the right of freedom of opinion is
of fundamental
importance this is stefan siebert
merkel's chief spokesman
telling reporters in berlin on monday
given that the chancellor considers it
problematic the president's accounts
have been permanently suspended siebert
said that while twitter was right to
flag at trump's inaccurate tweets
banning his accounts altogether
was a step too far man when the germans
are lecturing you about free speech
you have gone wildly wildly wrong by the
way it is not just angela merkel
it is also a putin critic named alexi
navalny
navalny's been an outspoken critic of
vladimir putin
very much in favor of free speech he
laid out 11 reasons why twitter's
purging of trump was a dangerous
precedent he said i think the ban of
trump on twitter is an unacceptable act
of censorship
he said yeah of course trump is
irresponsible of course he says
irresponsible things
but he says in my opinion the decision
to ban trump was based on emotions and
personal political preferences
don't tell me he was banned for
violating twitter rules i get death
threats here every day for many years
twitter doesn't ban anyone
among the people who have twitter
accounts are cold-blooded murderers like
putin and maduro
and liars and thieves like medvedev for
many years twitter facebook instagram
they've been used as a base for putin's
troll factory and similar groups from
other authoritarian countries
he's exactly right about all of this
we're now being warned
by people outside the united states that
the united states is too oppressive
if that's not depressing i'm not sure
what is okay we'll get to more of this
in just one moment because again the
push
is hardcore we'll also get to
impeachment which democrats are pushing
for a second time in just one second
first
let us talk about the fact that you
probably don't want to be going to an
auto parts store
right now or probably ever why would you
go to an auto parts store especially
because they're going to ask a bunch of
questions you don't know the answer to
then they're going to order a generic
part for you that it's going to take
three weeks to come online and they're
gonna upcharge you for all
of that wonderful service instead why
not just go get the part yourself cut
out the middleman head on over
to rockauto.com rockauto.com always
offers the lowest prices possible rather
than changing prices based on what the
market will bear
like the airlines do why would you spend
up to twice as much for the same parts
let's say
hypothetically just coming up with this
you know top of my head because this is
the kind of stuff i'm super into
you need like a delphi fg 1456 fuel pump
assembly for a 2005 to 2010 honda
odyssey
that'll cost you like 354 bucks at a big
chain store but at rockauto.com that's
gonna cost you 217 bucks
rockauto.com it's a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years we're talking about the best
available prices
same prices for do-it-yourselfers and
experts amazing selection go to
rockauto.com
right now see all the parts available
for your car or truck right shapiro in
there how did you hear about usbox so
they know
that we sent you that's rockauto.com go
check them out right now
okay we're gonna get some more of this
in just one second i gotta tell you the
actions of big tech last week
they've made it perfectly clear they're
going to do everything they can over the
coming months and years to silence
opposing voices
any excuse any excuse is going to be
used to silence
opposing voices they're out of control a
lot of people have been
asking us how you can help well listen
we've been telling you for a while
about our ambitious plans right
investigative news entertainment content
where we're bringing out our first movie
later this week with the actions big
tech
this week it's clear that this cannot
stop there really i mean
they literally remove the ability of
parlor to exist
online right they took away their web
services okay so
it's it's it's not enough for you just
to subscribe right
everybody needs to subscribe over at
dailywire.com the reason is because we
are now going to have to build or buy
tech to protect ourselves
from the attack that is coming so we can
continue to deliver new content to you
and fight back we're exploring all the
possibilities to insulate ourselves from
the cancellation
of all of these big companies that do
not care about freedom of speech
we're going to have to look at new data
centers and payment gateways a lot more
we have to build a parallel
infrastructure now because you can't
trust left-leaning corporations on this
stuff our team is hard at work on this
we cannot do all of that with our
current budget we are talking about
building
literally the entire infrastructure that
people have been spending decades
building we're talking about doing that
in short order which means that we need
a lot of your support
okay the reality again of the situation
is just that
all of the things that we thought we
could take for granted our ability to
contract with other companies
that we took it for granted because
everybody took it for granted
and now you are seeing that that is a
huge huge huge
mistake okay we need honestly to pay for
all this kind of stuff we're gonna need
to get up to like a million subscribers
a million members
now that's not impossible the washington
post has three million subscribers the
new york times has seven million
on the entertainment side facebook has
like 255 million monthly active users
netflix
has 73 million subscribers well if you
want us to challenge them
and if you need us to be able to
insulate ourselves so we actually can
challenge them
we need your membership if you believe
in what we've done so far they just
haven't been able to actually get a
membership
it's important to step up if you can and
help us win the fight
if you think that your freedoms are at
stake as big tech cracks down and it's
going to get worse over the coming years
okay because the democrats are going to
use their leverage now
to force big tech to do their bidding
that's what they've been doing for years
they've been threatening it
the republicans stood in their way now
they control all aspects of the
government
well now is your chance to fight back
you have to join daily wire to do so
we honestly don't know what they're
going to hit us with next which means we
have to prep for all available
possibilities whatever it is we are
going to beat them as long as you stand
with us
we are going to win so go become a
member at dailywire.com
subscribe tell all of your friends to do
the same
these these big tech bros are not our
friends they're going to wait until
the most plausible possible moment to
shut us down we have to prepare for it
if you like our content we need your
help please head on over to
dailywire.com
subscribe tell your friends to do the
same also
if you'd like to come work here at daily
wire we are hiring we have a bunch of
open positions right now we are looking
for an hr manager so head on over to
dailywire.com right now you can check
that out you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
so by the way if you thought that all of
the censorship stuff was a little bit
too on the nose
well now we are in the realm of actual
book
it so over the last 24 hours
antifa demanded that powell's books in
portland
shut down the store if they were if they
carried andy noe's book
on antifa so there are people in the
mainstream media pushing for this
i mean sarah zhang of the new york times
she was pushing for andy know to be
banned from twitter
why what was his grave crime he would go
to these antique rallies he would film
the anti-ferrari she'd put up the tape
of the anti-for rallies and then
he would identify with the photos the
people who had been arrested at the nt
for rallies
and when i say rallies i mean riots okay
but now
antifa showed up at uh at this portland
store called powell's books
and they demanded that the store stop
selling unmasked inside antifa's radical
plan to destroy democracy
that's the book by andy the protest
forced the store to close early
pells then announced it would not carry
the book in its physical store though it
would still
be available for purchase online the
book will not be on our store shelves
will not promote it
said powell's that said it will remain
in our online catalog
we carry books that we find anyway that
we find anywhere from simply distasteful
or badly written to excable
as well as those we treasure we believe
it is the work of book selling to do so
so uh here are some antifa protesters
outside powell's books explaining
that if they stopped the release of the
book that would be like stopping the
release of mein kampf here's some of
that footage
stop selling andy now's book you're on
the program
how can you help
[Applause]
yeah nothing nothing quite says
anti-fascism like in fascist fashion
closing a bookstore because someone was
writing about how terrible you are
by the way it's absolute cowardice for
pals to remove the book from the actual
shelves right that in and of itself
is absolute cowardice on an
extraordinary level i mean it is a
bookstore
if the idea here is that bookstores can
only carry books that the left agrees
with
and just like it is the idea here that
facebook is only allowed to allow posts
that facebook agrees with or twitter is
only allowed to allow posts the twitter
agrees with
and not only that if you are an outlet
that does not implement the same
standards as facebook or twitter does
with regard to its policing of content
that you can have your web service
removed
the culture of free speech is dead and
then once the culture of free speech is
dead
then it's just a question as to when the
law changes right because the culture
the law always follows the culture the
minute that the culture of free speech
dies in america
we're not very it's really just the
supreme court standing between
the left and the destruction of actual
legal free speech in the country
and we've had articles from people who
are now going to be in the biden
administration
talking openly about why we need to
adopt european standards with regard to
free speech
i.e banning quote unquote hate speech
meaning stuff that the left doesn't like
very often hate speech encompasses
everything from actual horrible speech
to things like saying that a transgender
man is actually still a biological woman
right if it were not for the the barrier
of the first amendment
as interpreted by the supreme court
there is no question the left would be
pushing for this stuff incredibly
incredibly hard right now
under the base on the basis of all of
this is a danger
all of this is incitement everything is
incitement remember this argument is old
okay just because of what happened at
the capitol does not mean that this is a
new argument it's been an old argument
that people were trying to shut down my
speeches at places like berkeley
requiring 600 police officers because
they were suggesting
that me standing in favor of free speech
was actually fascism right because words
are violence
words are violence this is literally
what they were chanting they're
they're chanting speech is violence the
punch and nazi movement
that that started a few years ago was
also completely reliant on the idea that
all of your fellow citizens are nazis if
they disagree with you
that is the direction the culture is
moving okay so let's say that you wish
to unify
let's say that you wished to come
together and promise unity well at that
point wouldn't you say listen we should
all be on the same page about some
fundamental principles
fundamental principles like freedom of
speech fundamental principles like
yes the truth matters and yes you should
acknowledge when an election
has not been stolen and yes you should
not push bad
legal analysis you should not do any of
that but this is all under the rubric of
free speech
and that has to be protected as well and
it's our job to speak out
more convincingly and more loudly it's
amazing to me that folks have said there
are no consequences to trump's
prevarications over the past few years
there's no consequences to trump being
trump
it seems like there's a pretty major
consequence that major consequence would
be
he's not going to be president january
20th and that's a pretty major
consequence is it not
he is the first president of the united
states not to win re-election
since george h.w bush in 1992
and he's the first president of the
united states not to win re-election
without a major third-party candidate
taking 15 to 20
of the votes since jimmy carter in 1980
okay he he lost the popular vote by
seven million votes
it seems like that's that's a a pretty
significant backlash to many of the
problems to trump
personally especially given the fact
that republicans
out balloted trump nearly everywhere
around the country there was almost a
personal rebuke to trump by the american
voter
but again the idea here from the left is
that we can't have unity unless you do
things we want
so joe biden is now promising unity
joe biden has announced that that will
be his theme america united
which is fine again i would like for
there to be some unity around some
shared principle that would be good and
again i think those shared principles
can be broad things like we believe in
freedom of speech and freedom of
religion and we should leave each other
alone and we should basically be nice to
each other
all of these things i think are fairly
broad they have a basic declaration
of independence principles freedom of
association freedom of speech
freedom of the press freedom of religion
right these are all things that we
should be in favor of
there is only one problem which is that
there are going to be some strings
attached
so senator ron wyden has a piece
over at nbc news in which he suggests
that the only way
for us to come back together is if you
do a bunch of stuff that senator ron
wyden would like
he says that that we need to change the
law right
that's the he says that
the what we need to do is we need a new
voting rights act
he says that we require the addition of
puerto rico and washington dc as states
he says we need universal mail and
balloting right this is how we're going
to achieve unity
he says that we the the way to to combat
the the violence that we just saw is
wait a second wait for it wait for it
all the things he wants to do
shock he says unless there's a
grassroots mobilization it'll be a
challenge to get significant republican
support for these proposals but the
alternative is
to proceed further with a dangerous
status quo one that got us a tyrant in
the white house
a violent attack on the capital and an
attempt to overturn the will of millions
of voters by violence and executive fiat
our democracy is fragile democrats have
an obligation to strengthen it
so the way that you stop what happened
at the capitol building is for making
washington dc a state
making puerto rico a state universal
mail and balloting
and a new voting rights act that
requires pre-clearance for all districts
democrats don't like
oh so what you what you mean by unity is
shut the hell up what you mean by unity
is watch as we rig
all the instruments of government in our
favor by adding four senators presumably
democrats willy-nilly
by ensuring that the federal government
now gets to screen
red states predominantly red states for
congressional redistricting and you know
just as like a side matter if you could
like do all these other things we want
also that'd be great universal mail and
balloting
yeah this it's it's all unity except by
unity they mean
do all the things we want to do and then
we can have unity right hillary rodham
clinton wrote a piece
in the washington post arguing exactly
this
right she said that wednesday's attack
on the capital was the tragically
predictable result of white supremacist
grievances
fueled by trump but his departure from
office will not solve the deeper
problems exposed
by the episode and uh and then she
compares what happened to
911 proper right she says almost 20
years later we are living through
another failure of imagination the
failure to account for the damage that
can be done to our nation by a president
who incites violence congressional
leaders who found the flames
and social media platforms that sear
conspiracy theories into the minds of
trump supporters
so by unity she means we're gonna have
to shut all this stuff down shut all of
it down it's not enough to scrutinize
the domestic terrorists we need to do
soul searching
on a broad american level and we need to
stop
anybody who disagrees with hillary
clinton yeah that sounds like a unifying
message guys
uh totally unifying okay speaking of
unifying messages
democrats are now looking at impeachment
of course
so they've proposed a a one article
impeachment proposal they're they're
accusing him of incitement of
insurrection
here is the resolution the second
impeachment resolution which presumably
will be passed today by a democratic
congress
resolve that donald john trump president
of the united states is impeached for
high crimes and misdemeanors and the
following article of impeachment be
exhibited to the united states senate
article of impeachment exhibited by the
house of representatives of the united
states in the name itself and of the
people of the united states
article one the constitution provides
that the house of representatives shall
have the sole power of impeachment and
that the president shall be removed from
office on impeachment for and conviction
of
treason bribery other high crimes and
misdemeanors further section 3 of the
14th amendment to the constitution
prohibits any person who has engaged in
insurrection or rebellion against the
united states from holding any office
under the united states
in his conduct while president of the
united states and in violation of his
constitutional oath
faithfully to execute the office of
president of the united states and to
the best of his ability preserve protect
to defend the constitution
in violation of his constitutional duty
to take care of the laws be faithfully
executed
donald john trump engaged in high crimes
and misdemeanors by inciting violence
against
the united states government in that on
january 6
pursuant to the 12th amendment of the
constitution of the united states the vp
house of representatives and senate met
at the united states capitol for a joint
session of congress to count the votes
of the electoral college and this is all
the
impeachment charge the democrats are
bringing against trump in the months
preceding the joint session
president trump repeatedly issued false
statements asserting that the
presidential election results were the
product of widespread fraud and should
not be accepted by the american people
or certified by state and federal
officials
shortly before the joint session
commenced president trump addressing a
crowd at the ellipse in washington dc
there he reiterated false claims that we
won this election and we wanted by a
landslide
he also willfully made statements that
in context encouraged and foreseeably
resulted in
lawless action at the capitol such as if
you don't fight like hell you're not
gonna have a country anymore
okay um that is about the vaguest
political statement
in the world i mean like really you can
find
nearly every major american politician
talking about fighting for things
right it's a staple diet of american
politics does that mean that trump
wasn't being irresponsible no
does that mean that he was actively
inciting violence which is the charge
here gonna be very very difficult to
prove that if this ever gets to a senate
trial
which again i'm doubtful that it will
considering the timeline here
it's gonna be extraordinarily difficult
to prove that trump who said in the
speech
that people should peacefully protest
outside the capitol building
meant invade the capitol building hogged
the vice president of the united states
and overthrow the federal government
right it's gonna be a very difficult
stretch for uh for for proof
in the united states senate right so
thus incited by president trump members
of the crowd he had addressed in an
attempt to among other objectives
interfere with joint sessions
solemn constitutional duty to certify
the results of the 2020 presidential
election unlawfully breached and
vandalized the capital injured and
killed law enforcement personnel
menaced members of congress the vp and
congressional personnel and engaged in
other violent deadly destructive
insidious acts
president trump's conduct followed his
prior efforts to subvert and obstruct
the certification of the results of the
2020 presidential election
those prior efforts included a phone
call on january 2 2021
during which trump urged the secretary
of state of georgia brad rafensberger to
find enough votes to overturn
the georgia presidential election
results and threaten secretary
raffensberger if he failed to do so we
talked about that call at the time it
was both a bad call
and also he didn't have anything he
could threaten raffensberger with
and frankly it sounds like he was just
repeating a bunch of the conspiratorial
nonsense
about tens of thousands of votes being
hidden or fraudulently
cast and uh and he believes his own
press
when it comes to this sort of stuff so
it wasn't about manufacturing votes it
was about
finding votes trump believed existed
even though that happens to be not true
in the remote in the in the remotest
detail in all this
says the impeachment charge trump
gravely endangered the security of the
united states and its institutions of
government
he threatened the integrity of the
democratic system interfered with the
peaceful transition of power
and imperil the co-equal branch of
government and so he should be uh
impeached and removed from office that
is the article of impeachment
which presumably uh is going to be
passed today
by the house democrats now is that going
to go anywhere
no it's not going to go anywhere because
the fact of the matter is that in order
for
the senate to even come back into
session you have to have an agreement
from both schumer and mcconnell to do
that
second even if it were to come back into
session you then have to have an actual
senate trial
the senate trial is going to have
witnesses it is going to delve into
detail
about the attempted insurrection and
what was the connection to trump
personally
right the the consequences to trump
are are forget about impeachment right
now the idea that trump has suffered no
consequences
trump is a pariah right okay politically
speaking he is a pariah
what this means is that that trump is
basically i mean he's his own party has
basically turned on him
he has uh he has essentially been cast
from the public square
has a 33 approval rating right now
he lost his election he's not coming
back
right all of that is the consequence of
the rhetoric that he has shown over the
past couple of months
all of that is the consequence of of the
stuff that he has been saying and by the
way
kevin mccarthy is proposing what i think
is probably a better solution to all of
this
which is censure right accenture is a
congressional censure that basically
it's it's a note
chiding whomever it is right the
democrats didn't pass
a note of censure against ilhan omar for
example but that's what accenture is
so kevin mccarthy who is the house
minority leader
he put out a letter to his fellow
republicans he says
having spoken to so many of you i know
we are all taking time to process the
events of that day
please know i share your anger and your
pain zip ties were found on staff desks
in my office windows were smashed in
property was stolen those images will
never leave us i think our men and women
in law enforcement who continue to
protect us and are working to bring the
sick individuals who perpetrated these
attacks to justice
in the same breath i've also heard
profound resolve from our conference in
the face of this evil
personally i continue to believe that an
impeachment at this time would have the
opposite effect of bringing the country
together when we need to get america
back on a path toward unity and civility
notwithstanding the speaker's push
forward impeachment i have heard from
members across our conference who have
raised at least four potential avenues
to the house
to ensure that the events of january 6th
are rightfully denounced these include
a resolution of censure under the rules
of the house a bipartisan commission to
investigate the circumstances
surrounding the attack
reforming the electoral account act of
1897 to clarify what the process
is and legislation to promote voter
confidence in future
federal elections okay that that seems
to make an awful lot of sense to me
a resolution of censure for trump's
behavior i think is perfectly within
balance i think it is perfectly
plausible and it makes
a lot of sense is impeachment the proper
solution especially given the fact that
we are not talking about months until he
is out of office we are talking about
literally one week until he is out of
office
uh i think that that is likely not only
to to not be successful
i think it is likely to carry on beyond
the election which is of course what
many democrats are proposing jim clyburn
wants this to carry on for months
so that this can continue to be used as
sort of a cudgel against republicans
more broadly
but bottom line here is that impeachment
if it's urgent enough that it needs to
be done right now
then democrats should have passed this
thing like
as of last friday right democrats should
have pushed this thing to the floor
extremely fast instead they were waiting
until wednesday to vote on it they
wanted to encourage pence to invoke the
25th amendment nancy pelosi did
something that probably
is not super constitutional she she
encouraged the joint chiefs of staff to
basically end around trump
in case of some sort of national crisis
which actually amounts to
uh legally speaking an infringement of
the executive
power obviously here is here's the
bottom line
is impeachment is some form of censure
of the president merited on the basis of
what we have seen
yes of course is impeachment the proper
solution with one week to go
i don't think that it is i don't think
you can make the legal case that it is
again
high crimes and misdemeanors requires
like a crime or a misdemeanor
trump ain't gonna get charged in a court
of law on this stuff things can be bad
without them being fully criminal
and for those who keep saying you know
what what would hap you know
we need to stop this sort of thing from
happening in the future
okay first of all this sort of thing
i can guarantee you we're never going to
have giant riots of the capital building
again
that's not going to happen again too
trump has been defeated he is leaving
right we have a week to go so if you
actually want unity at this point here
is what we should do
we should look at the country as a whole
and we should recognize that our fellow
citizens
are generally not in favor of rioting at
the capitol or threatening the vice
president of the united states
we should recognize that this difficult
moment is a difficult moment
that we have some soul searching to do
as a country but not because
all of our fellow citizens are racists
or white supremacists or bigots who
who are who are awful people the soul
searching we have to do is what are the
principles that we wish to hold in
common
and i think that does require some
soul-searching on the right about the
willingness to confront confirmation
bias about the willingness
to accept fact as they are presented
and i think that after that is done and
i think there is an order to this
i think the right has to lead the way
because obviously what we saw
was an element of the right doing this
but i think the left has some soul
searching to do of its own
what is not going to work here is
unilateral soul-searching on one side
and triumphalism on the other
that is not geared toward healing the
country in any serious way
and in con in in the context of that in
the context of the search for unity
we're all going to have to recommit
ourselves to some first basic principles
yes on the right basic principles of
fact-finding and belief in fact
and understanding that evidence is
necessary for claims on the left
you're gonna have to do the same thing
with regard to some of your stuff you're
also gonna have to respect the right of
people to disagree with you after
examining the fact
because of what this comes down to is
just stomp your opponents whenever you
have an opportunity to do so this stuff
is going to get a lot worse it is not
going to get better
anytime in the near future alrighty
we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content in
the meantime head on over to the michael
knowles show he discusses twitter
removing
removing 70 000 q anon accounts you can
hear more details about that story over
on michael's show that is available
right now
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez
the show is edited by adam's psy events
audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is by fabiola
christina production assistant jessica
crams
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021.
house democrats try to impeach president
trump andrew cuomo finally promises to
open up new york
and kamala graces the cover of vogue
check it out on the michael knowles show